you will find some customers that are
very technical or they have an aptitude
and they won they won't you know pop the
hood and understand how the product
works especially early on because you're
selling them a promise so they want to
see that the the the components of the
promise can actually deliver on the
promise but eventually customers want
outcomes they want they've got a problem
they want you to solve it they don't
care about the technology they want it
to work they want it to be easy to
consume they want their teams to be able
to you know to to to use it Implement
and achieve the goals that they want um
you know I've been in situations I I've
always used
this um this comparison of competitive
situations in which I found myself
whether it was with sayota or whether it
was you know in capsula versus other
competitors which we always thought that
they had inferior technology to us but
they did really really well um and a lot
of it that was you know
appearance um we always say you never
judge a book by its cover uh customers
judge books but you know the products by
their cover if the cover is not you know
doesn't look like a million
[Music]
dollars Mark Gaffin welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for being here
it's great to be here thanks for having
me I really appreciate your time h mark
you've been at the cyber security
landscape for a long time 20 years 20
years and today you're definitely
considered one of the you know most
amazing entrepreneurs here in the not
only the Israel ecosystem but in the
Cyber ecosystem and um and the companies
that you've been a part of and today
you're leading I think are really at the
consistently are looking at the way that
the cyber security is evolving and I
know from as as a cyber security
entrepreneur I'm taking a lot of
inspiration from the work that you're
doing and the way that you're that
you're looking at the at both at the
market but also from a product
perspective so I'm excited to just go
back with you to your journey
and to then dive into ionics and to
understand a little bit better what
you're doing today and how is cyber
security evolved in terms of the threat
landscape and how do organizations map
the risks and the vulnerabilities that
the connect that the connected world is
facing them today so again thank you for
being here how did you get into cyber in
the first place very much by luck um I
wasn't a uh typical Israeli um offensive
cyber attacker in the military I was a
uh a real Soldier um I hope none of my
kids take offense to that cuz I have
both um what are they doing in the Army
I have a uh my oldest daughter was a
combatant in the artillery Corps she's a
a reservist that uh unfortunately spent
about 170 days of the last year wow uh
so she's a med med school uh student in
the teon but she also spent about 170
days uh in reserve juty over the last 14
months and I have a
20-year-old who's an 8200 guy and I have
a senior at school so still uh TBD
amazing so you started not in the tech
sector in the Army which is which is a
lot of how the Cyber industry is right
um learned to work in a team um you know
that's what I did in the military um
studied computer science and economics
when I finished the military uh um
didn't really know that I wanted to do
computer science but I kind of stumbled
on that as well after my military
service I went to work in a paper mill
as uh someone who who came to help the
computers guy the the computer team
there or the the information systems
team there um I was looking to make some
money to save up for uh an after
military uh trip realized that was
pretty interesting got pretty good at it
um and then decided to study it so I
studied computer science after I
finished I um coded for a bunch of years
ran a bunch of development teams then
realized that I was less into building
but more into trying to sell so I moved
into product management roles uh my last
product management role was uh
or at some stage during my product
management career um my wife and I and a
2 and a half year-old moved from Israel
to to New Jersey um and two years into
relocation there I got a phone call from
a a head hunter said hey I'm looking for
a someone to lead product management and
product marketing for this company uh I
took a look um Turned out it was an
Israeli company um I they didn't know
that I was Israeli they didn't know that
this would be this would have an appeal
um that company was called sayota most
people know it as naali bennets company
today but that was my first cyber
security gig basically so I did I I I
zero background um I came in I ran
product management product marketing uh
it was kind of a bit of a combination
back then um a year into that Journey we
got acquired by
RSA after that at RSA I ran um product
marketing for the entire RSA portfolio
which back then was one of the bigger
cyber security companies and then
um couple years later we moved back to
Israel and I founded a company called
Inc capsu
together with G who I think that you
actually uh had on this podcast in the
past so gur and I found it in capsula um
four years into that Journey things
started to pick up and take off uh I
packed up my family um we went to live
in Palo
Alto um and about a year after we moved
we sold the company to impera I stayed
on at impera for a couple of years
incapsula became the biggest product
line within impera cross $100 million in
ARR uh it was really a great great ride
and he perect gave us a lot of Runway to
to to to stay uh to some extent
independent so we had literally our our
own sales and marketing you know um
teams and um in 2017 I moved on I uh
took took some time off um I met some of
the partners at besser who said to me if
you're going to do nothing come do
nothing here uh which was a great
experience I spent a year there a half
of the time was that in their SF office
yeah so this wasn't in this was in the
back then their their their menow Park
office um so I spent time with mostly
with David cow in there and then halfway
through that journey I we decided to
move back to to Israel and then I spent
time at the bester office here with Adam
and Amit
um got to see the dark side to realize
that it's not that dark um and I really
had a good time with you
know understanding the other side of the
perspective which is you know super
important and then I joined a teammate
company a CEO company called isolate uh
we did desktop isolation or endpoint
isolation we sold that company a couple
of years ago and uh my recent gig is
with ionics which I will be celebrating
my 2-year anniversary there on the 1st
of January so just in a couple of weeks
wow
um yeah so that's that's what I'm doing
right now if you're looking at at this
journey and what what are the connecting
dots for you I hear of a journey of
going from Builder to to looking at
product and a lot of looking at the the
fit from the product to the
market what what has been the part of
this journey that you've found most
fulfilling personally so you know um
this is my second gig as as not a not a
founding CEO and I actually hate the
term professional CEO um I think of
myself more as an entrepreneurial CEO I
like to come when things are early stage
when product Market fit is not that
clear uh or it's just starting to you
know signal to clear up there's some
signals and what what and what does that
look like the some signals for you so
you get custom you get prospects that
are interested in what you're doing um
they you know you're solving a real
problem and um then the question is can
you convert or can you come up with a
solution that is a to their uh their
pain points can you can they implement
it and I went from a cloud-based
Security Service like encapsula which
was frictionless in terms of
implementation to a company like isolate
that the implementation was very very
very difficult these are things that you
learn on you know on the way um finding
product Market it is finding a pain to a
real to finding a solution to a real
pain that customers can adopt and it's
not easy to to adopt even if they've got
a big pain and you've got a great
solution if they can't adopt it because
of multiple constraints um it's not
going to take off and you got to be
better than your competitors so those
are the things that you've got to come
up with in order to to to make it work
and then of course you've got to there's
that's just the product Market fit which
is also not a binary thing so product
Market fit is not either you've got
product Market fit or you haven't it
comes in uh more than 50 Shades of Gray
and it's constantly changing because the
competitive landscape is changing
the problem that you're trying to solve
evolves the requirements involve
customers mature you help them with
stage one of the problem and then they
need you to help them with stage two and
three and four of that problem so
there's a constant evolution in terms of
what you do in ter you know in terms of
product Market fit and I like that I
like talking to customers understanding
what their problems are trying to come
up with solutions that I think we can we
can we can solve and it's not just as I
said it's not just a technological
solution it's trying to factor in the
technology the visibility of
implementation the competitive
positioning that you've got those are
the things that I like trying to fuse
together I mean in a lot of ways um it
feels that a a big part of it is not
just the is is the te the technology one
would think because we're also in a deep
Tech ecosystem and many of the things
that you get to deal with that you got
to do and you get to do today are you
know are technologically heavy from the
customers in the market perspective do
they even care about the technology
because what you're saying here is that
a lot of it the attention is on the
visibility is it a real enough problem
you know can you actually implement it
and and will it function better than the
competitors I haven't heard of you know
what's the technology here and who cares
about that I think that most customers
don't care about the technology you will
find some customers that are very
technical or they have an aptitude and
they W they want you know pop the hood
and understand how the product works
especially early on because you're
selling them a promise so they want to
see that the the the components of the
promise can actually deliver on the
promise but event customers want
outcomes they want they've got a problem
they want you to solve it they don't
care about the technology they want it
to work they want it to be easy to
consume they want their teams to be able
to you know to to to use it Implement
and achieve the goals that they want um
you know I've been in situations I I've
always used
this um this comparison of competitive
situations in which I found myself
whether it was with sayota or whether it
was you know in capsula versus other
competitors which we always thought that
they had inferior technology to us but
they did really really well um and a lot
of it that was you know appearance um we
always say you never judge a book by its
cover uh customers judge books but you
know the products by their cover if the
cover is not you know doesn't look like
a million dollars they're not even going
to open the book especially if they are
walking in the corridors of a massive
library and there are so many books on
the shelves that they've got to find
that they've got to see the book that
that that's you know that really
attracts them and I use that obviously
as an analogy especially you know in in
the the cyber security space um security
teams are getting
calls every day everyone's fighing for
attention everyone's got a problem to
solve their current solution their
current everyone's got a solution to
solve their current problem yesterday's
problem that they've solded that they've
found a better way to solve tomorrow's
problem that they haven't even thought
about um so it's a super competitive
environment you've really got a shine
from the beginning meaning meaning the
presentation that you do
the PO that you do of course the
product's going to look needs to look
like a million dollars uh we always tend
to think hey B2B products technologists
the product doesn't need to be you know
super fine and and and user experience
isn't that important it's so important
uh we
we many of our customers are not able to
dive into the deep details of what
what's the what's the technological
difference between us and another you
know another competitor or another
product they judge things emotionally
superficially based on Word of Mouth or
reputation those are things that you got
to get in order to really scale and then
that's a little bit counterintuitive I
think to a lot of entrepreneurs uh
especially in our in our ecosystem here
in Israel right I mean we're we're
growing up from 8200 not everybody but a
lot of the Cyber entrepreneurs
especially today right one here that you
grow up thinking okay wow I have this
this incredible technology that I'm so
proud of and I'm putting 90% of my
effort there but it's actually that's a
that's a that's a a bias it should be
90% on on how do you frame it to the
customer that fits their needs and their
constraints is and it needs to work
obviously but we don't nearly give
enough attention to the presentation
right and I would say that it's it's
almost on two fronts one is actually
understanding the customers environment
so does this product fit into their
environment how does it solve a problem
that they've that they've got um the
other is also understanding your
audience we tend to think you know and
I've seen this a lot with a lot
of really smart 8200 graduates and tax
in general that they often don't realize
that the audience that's going to
operate the
tools um is an audience that is way less
skilled from a techn you know not
everyone's a nation state
attacker um and you're Building Products
that need to be made accessible to
hundreds of thousands of you know uh of
security analysts technicians sock
operators um you know it's it's it's
it's literally like you know not
everyone can fly a rocket ship most
people can drive a car and that's how
transportation's been made accessible
we've got to take that into
consideration when we build products
both in terms of how to use them
understanding them realizing the value
it's all it needs to be made accessible
to the to the the very broad audience
you're actually going to be using the
product so I'd love to hear how how
you've made that accessible in in ionics
but take me a step back for a second so
two years ago in two weeks er um you had
you joined ionics as CEO and you know
obviously we're living in in an ultra
connected World assets are getting more
and more connected by the day we're
seeing vertical AI agents shooting
through the roof and my estimate is that
the world will become 10 times more
connected over the next just couple of
years simply due to the sheer Innovation
that we have with all of the tools that
that AI will bring in a verticalized way
what what is you know starting from the
pain point the problem to be solved what
does this mean for organizations this
Ultra activity so you know when I before
I joined I obviously spent time with a
company doing my own due diligence on do
I want to spend my next 10 years you
know doing this you'd never know how
long these Journeys are um and when
I when I looked at the problem I
realized that the problem that we're out
to solve is a is a is a challenging
problem and I I almost when I try to
define the problem that we're trying to
solve it's just three or four-pillar
problem um the attack surface of an
organization is growing on an ongoing
basis exponentially more and more assets
are spinning up so much more
infrastructure days is driven by code
and one of the biggest challenges that
the infrastructure that we have today is
not just run by the organization it's
run by your partners by your vendors so
the span of control that you have across
your tax office is is somewhat
challenging or is very challenging the
second thing is the amount of changes
that we do across the tax surface um
studies are showing that 5% of your
digital assets go through a config
change and upgrade a a software upgrade
every single month so there's massive
change going on across that attack
surface and the third problem is that
the land the threat landscape is
changing every single day so I think
last year there were 40,000 cves that
were published uh how do you take those
three pillars or those three vectors of
chaos essentially now fuse them into
something that that's going to help us
protect our uh our attack surfaces and
the one of the most difficult attack
surfaces to protect is what we call your
external attacks it's everything that's
internet facing because the the
challenge there is that if you have an
asset that's been misconfigured or has
an exploitable vulnerability it's a
Sitting Duck on the internet and the bad
guys are constantly looking constantly
scanning that's going to be you know
that's your initial perimeter we talk
about perimeter lless organizations but
your internet facing assets are um are
essentially your perimeter today they
could be super distributed in multiple
data centers across the globe by
Partners Etc but that's that's what the
external world or the external attackers
that are constantly looking for ways in
are are probing at and the time in which
they today are weaponizing is a lot
faster uh they use co-pilot as well to
code their exploits and to you know to
to to to convert cves into real EXP
exploitable uh proof of Concepts that
they can actually break into or they can
actually hack you know different assets
that problem seemed to me like a problem
that's only going to get worse um and
when I looked at the you know the
the the handful of customers that the
company had back then um these were I
would say the cesos of the security
teams that were on The Cutting Edge um I
really identifi them as those that were
you know Visionaries that understood the
technology that understood the problem
those were already good signs for me as
okay there's already adoption in the
space and that's what we've been doing
you know for the so for the last two
years that's where we've been focusing
on um company's growing very very very
nicely many of the fortun 500 companies
in the world today use us um it's been a
great journey over the next you know
over the last two years and I'm hoping
that the next I don't know if it's 1 2 3
10 years um you know are just as good so
super interesting space really really
good team that's what got me excited and
uh the Journey's been great now is is it
fair to assess
that due to the way that that AI agents
are operating today and their projected
growth that any Sitting Duck asset you
you call those assets with
vulnerabilities as sitting ducks and I'm
thinking to myself boy I mean the way
that we're heading is that we're going
to have these AI agents that can go and
look for these sitting D pretty much
automatically especially if you have
some motivation to do that and then you
know try and assess and and find them
and so any Sitting Duck quickly becomes
a shoting Target um to any any anyone
leveraging AI agents for this task so
how how do you see the the attack
potential changing due to the world that
we're moving into so I think that the
there two key things that I need to that
I think need to happen on the def on the
on the defensive side in order for us to
be able to deal with the the attackers
and the evolution as you mentioned that
they're going through in terms of AI and
the automation that they're going to
introduce and that's they're basically
going to be able to move at a at a at a
faster speed that they are moving today
and the challenge is big enough today
you think about large organizations they
have to present 100 they have to protect
100% of their assets 100% of the time uh
bad guys need to there's this asymmetry
between the attackers and the defenders
in the attackers only need to get in
once you know they need to find one hole
in and and the the the challenge there
is
um how do you how do you combat that at
scale um obviously you know we use AI as
well and the the way that we found or
the the the the thesis that we have
around how to solve this is um first of
all being being prepared meaning um
mapping out an organization's attack
surface as accurately as possible and
the other thing which is even more
important is trying to really understand
the real exposures that organizations
have versus the 10,000 cves that they uh
that they have in theory which only a
few are actually
exploitable our goal is to find those
real
exploitable um misconfiguration
cves that the organization has that is
are most likely going to introduce most
of the exposure that an organization has
so being able to constantly be looking
at an organization understanding what
their weaknesses are evaluating them
with a lot of context okay is the cve
really reachable is it really
exploitable what's its blast radius what
else would it be able to impact figuring
all that out on a continuous basis is
what will give us an an advantage over
the the bad guys which are probing
hoping to find something that is
exploitable that is essentially an entry
point to something that has a blast
radius that is worthwhile the investment
being proactive around it and
understanding the context is help is
hopefully how we help our customers um
win that war give me a little bit more
into the the world of uh from Theory to
practicality in the context of of your
line of work and in cyber security in
general because fine you have 10,000
cves a lot of them are in theory you
give a c so listen you have 10,000 CVS
they'll say well what do I do with that
right so talk to me a little bit more
about how to translate theoretical risk
to practical risk in your line of work
so it's it's a great question and a good
observation I um I think I Rec recently
wrote a blog post on our website talking
about the fact that security teams are
drowning
invisibility now that's kind of an
oxymoron because everyone says hey I
need visibility we need perfect
visibility we need perect Vis perfect
visibility in order to solve you know
the problem the challenge is that that V
that visibility is become noise um and
the if you look at the initial evolution
of the category the external attack
surface management category that we we
play in or we we play in or played in it
was all all about help me map out my
attack surface effectively cuz I've got
lot of blind spots I've got Shadow it
I've got vendors I've got assets that we
thought we decommission but we didn't
really decommission and we've got Shadow
it and all that help us get visibility
what transpired after that first wave of
Discovery is that organizations are
saying okay so what do I do with all
this now you're telling me I've got a
you know a web server that's running an
old version of Apache and it's got you
know 55 cves on it um you've just
created more work for me should we
really patch them which of them should
we really patch you know um there's a
consensus teams cannot patch everything
the old way in which we did
vulnerability management cannot
scale mainly because of those three
chaos vectors that I that that that I
just mentioned too many cves too many
assets too many changes and time so
those are the things that those are the
constraints that we've got to solve and
the way or the approach that we've taken
is we we this is a marketing slogan we
want to give you the broadest coverage
but the sharpest Focus so that you know
exactly what to fix and in order to
determine that you need a lot of
context so I can give you an example of
how we would attack a specific you know
cve or a problem so of course we'll find
that same website or that same web
server that's got those 55
cves but out of those 55
cves 40 of them are cves that
are not really exploitable from the
outside so you've got to be in your
network you've got to have certain
privileges already to do that meaning
they're less important and most security
organizations will treat them with you
know with less importance or less
urgency out of those 15 that are now
applicable to an external attacker 10
are there's there's never been a PC
found in the wild for that meaning it's
a cve but no one's really built an
exploitation capability around it the
chances of an Enterprise getting
attacked with that type of a vector is
Slim it can happen that's that's what
zero days are are about but first of all
zero days when they come out or when
they discovered the market addresses
them um so now you've got only five of
those 55 that potentially could be
exploitable and are being exploited in
the Wild by the bad guys you have to
test so what we provide our customers is
is a is an actual test to see whether
that specific weakness or cve is in fact
exploitable and we'll find
that only one of them is really
exploitable now why were the other four
not exploitable first of all some of
those or that asset may be sitting
behind some type of a compensating
control they may be sitting behind a
firewall or may be sitting behind a web
application firewall or network server
that essentially mitigates a lot of
those threats so in theory they would
have been exploitable but in practice
there's some type of mitigating measure
in place that makes that benign you take
all that into consideration now from
55 things that you would have gone and
tried to patch in the previous world to
one cve that you know is reachable is
exploitable um and that's where you need
to focus that's what you can do through
you know through Auto
and that's what we're trying to do
essentially for our customers really
focus them on the most important things
that they need to fix um where they
really are exploitable and where most of
the exposure will come from broadest
coverage and sharpest Focus I have
that's the kudos to my marketing
team I have it written down um how do
you from your from your experience
you've you've been on the product
marketing and sales side for four
companies now
soota
impera isolate
ionics what does it come down to to
building a product that that security
teams really love once implemented so we
talked a little bit about the sales once
you're in there and it provides the
value that it claim that it says you're
you're going to provide how do you get
them to really love the product that
you're building does that exist do
security teams love products I do think
that security teams do love certain
products
um the products need to work for their
users and not vice versa I meaning we
need to get our products to work for our
users not our users to work for the
products mhm and that's that's important
we also need to realize that our
customers the users of our products
don't sleep eat breathe our products
like we do they don't know every single
Corner in the product they sometimes log
into the product once every couple of
days every couple of weeks um we've got
to realize that they that it's a task
that they often don't do on an ongoing
basis and we have to help them do those
tasks as easily as possible so products
need to be intuitive there's great ways
today even with AI agents to make the
product even more accessible in fact I
have a theory that products will not
look like the products that they
products will not look like the way they
look today uh 5 years from now you're
not going to into a product and you're
going to have to look for the menu item
or for the button there's going to be or
there should be an agent there that says
Hey I want to do this and either takes
you exactly to that page and to that
function or actually does it for you so
the whole interface is going to be a lot
more there you're going to have a
personal assistant in every application
that really is taking you through the
the the the journey uh which is a great
opportunity for us to change the way in
which we use product we just got to do
that quickly and I think that that you
know the last two years in terms of AI
have made this possible um my directive
to my to my team is that's that's the
future of how companies are going to
consume product we need to go in that
direction right and the the translation
is instead of coming in and seeing a big
dashboard with a bunch of the VIS with a
bunch of the sharp vulnerabilities you
have a sort of a Jarvis that you talk to
about okay these are the five cves that
we actually should take care of and and
here's how you would want to take care
of them oh and by the way while you were
sleeping we actually took care of it uh
and so you can continue on your day
correct I mean even data analysts or if
you're going in and making a config
change in your application why would you
go and have to figure out where that
specific screen is on to make that
config why wouldn't you just talk to an
agent or write to an agent say hey I
want to add a user to the um to the
system this is their email this is their
their phone number bam it's done um I
want to you know can you produce a
report with a B CDE e f and g uh and I
want to see you know for this specific
time span that's our that's our product
are going to be used um zero learning
curve that's really where products need
to go because the technology is
available now to do that mhm absolutely
mark this was such an awesome
conversation thank you so much for being
here and for joining me and for sharing
with me both about your own journey and
and that of ionx uh best of luck and uh
I can't wait to continue being inspired
from the side thanks much it's great
having uh great being on the uh on the
show thank you